bien monsieur le président chers
collègues chers amis qui est 12 cents
rassemblés ici ce matin et je salue
d'ailleurs particulièrement ceux nos
amis qui écoutant en retransmission dans
dans la salle du bail dans le hall
d'accueil
si nous avons décidé la tenue de ces
états généraux
et si j'ai proposé au président de notre
formation de les conclure en s'adressant
à vous militant de paris c'est parce
qu'après les heures sombres que notre
mouvement a traversé c'était l'occasion
de lancer le signal d'un nouveau départ
pour notre fédération
ces épreuves nous les avons surmontées
tous ensemble les liens qui nous
unissent ont été plus solides que les
déchirures et l'appel que je vous ai
lancé à l'époque vous exhortons à paris
à ne pas perdre espoir l'a bien confirmé
puisque presque aucun d'entre vous n'a
renvoyé sa carte d'adhérent à l'époque
j'étais alors impressionné je vous le
dis par l'attitude exemplaire qui a été
la vôtre
l'esprit de responsabilité l'a emporté
il ne s'agissait pas seulement de
l'avenir de notre parti mais aussi de
celui de notre pays puisque nous
constituons la première force
d'opposition la seule capable d'offrir
aux français une alternative crédible
oui vous avez eu raison de ne pas
abandonner de persévérer car aujourd'hui
vous voici toute sensibilité réunis pour
travailler au service des parisiens et
préparer l'alternance ce résultat nous
le devons aussi bien sûr et surtout à
l'application de notre président a
refondé à partie abîmée s'efforçant que
chacun y trouve à nouveau sa place avec
nathalie kosciusko morizet chargée de
rédiger les nouveaux statuts
vous avez pu donner votre avis non
seulement par internet mais aussi lors
d'une réunion des adhérents parisien que
j'avais convoqué à cet effet ici même et
cette reconstruction était indispensable
pour nous conduire à la victoire hier
pour les départementales demain pour les
régionales avec valérie pécresse en ile
de france et à paris avec pierre yves
bournazel
qui arrive quel est le candidat de la
jeunesse et du renouveau mais aussi le
candidat du terrail qui connaît donc
parfaitement les préoccupations des
parisiens mais c'est vous seul
par votre mobilisation qui remporterait
cette bataille en convainquant nos
concitoyens de l'impact des politiques
régionales d'abord dans leur vie
quotidienne emploi éducation transport
sécurité même et en les appelant dans un
scrutin qui est aussi nationale a rejeté
la politique de françois hollande comme
lors de l'élection départementale
valérie pécresse est venue nous rappeler
les enjeux de cette élection dans la
matinée
valérie peut compter sur paris elle peut
compter sur les parisiens pour lui
apporter les voix de la victoire car le
poids de paris vous le savez sera
déterminant je remercie aussi bien sûr
françois fillon de nous avoir fait part
de sa vision de l'avenir et d'avoir
démasqué la maire de paris madame tout
va bien merci aux nombreux élus de paris
présents les maires d'arrondissement
jean françois legaret florence berthaud
jean pierre lecoq delphine bürkli
brigitte huster les parlementaires
pierre lellouche bernard debré jean
françois lamour claude goasguen pierre
charon et philippe dominati d'être
présents ainsi que les nombreux
conseillers de paris et d'arrondissement
ces états généraux nous ont aussi amené
à traiter de deux préoccupations
majeures des parisiens la sécurité et le
logement
je remercie pierre yves bournazel et
frédéric péchenard d'avoir animé les
tables rondes correspondante avec des
invités de choix et surtout pour avoir
proposé des solutions à concrètes et
innovantes bien d'autres questions bien
évidemment reste à traiter tels
l'éducation les transports la fiscalité
ou encore l'urbanisme qui seront à
l'ordre du jour des prochains états
généraux que nous avons décidé avec
frédéric d'instituer chaque année on y
associant encore davantage en amont les
circonscriptions
ces états généraux sont bien sûr une
occasion pour faire le point sur les
activités sur l'état de la fédération
nous avons pu ainsi ce matin nous
approprier les nouvelles formes de
militantisme qui permette que permettent
de développer les nouveaux statuts
grâce à une base militante élargi à une
démocratie interne
revivifiée à des consultations directes
par internet mais aussi entamer une
autre étape de la vie de notre
fédération
grâce à la mise en place d'une nouvelle
équipe départementale que je salue et
que je vous demande d'applaudir pour les
encourager dans leur futur travail
sachez aussi que nos statuts nous
permettent désormais une question
importante que beaucoup de vous posais
d'organiser l'action militante au niveau
de l'arrondissement
c'est souvent à paris le bon niveau de
la mobilisation militante tout en
maintenant bien sûr la structure de la
circonscription et plus particulièrement
en perspective des législatives bien sûr
dans la gestion de l'ensemble se fera
évidemment par la fédération
installé depuis qu depuis peu ici même
dans les locaux de la rue de vaugirard
il ne s'agit pas seulement vous le corps
est bien compris d'un changement
d'adressé ni d'une simple source
d'économie certes non négligeable ce
retour à la maison mère était une
nécessité
j'ai toujours pensé pour ma part que la
structure parisienne de notre parti
devait évoluer en étroite symbiose avec
l'échelon national c'est à la fois
vitales pour la bonne marche de la
première fédération de france mais
également aussi avantageux pour le
centre national qui peut ainsi s'appuyer
à paris
on le voit aujourd'hui notamment sur une
base militante opérationnel et
mobilisables c'est pour cette même
raison que j'ai approuvé et ô combien la
nomination par notre président comme
nouveau secrétaire départemental de
notre collègue du conseil de paris
frédéric péchenard au calme ni inhabitée
anciennes
la fonction de directeur général des
républicains est la meilleure garantie
d'une étroite coopération entre
l'échelon fédéral l'échelon national
l'assurance d'un développement optimal
de notre fédération
déjà la première de france avec ses 25
mille adhérents et dont le niveau de
progression nous placent aussi dans le
peloton de tête des fédérations qui
recrutent le plus même si ce n'est
jamais assez et j'en profite pour lancer
cet appel au renouvellement et au
recrutement nouveaux adhérents auprès de
vous cette volonté de rassemblement
elle préside également aux relations
sans nuages que la fédération entretien
avec le groupe du conseil de paris très
efficacement dirigée par nathalie
kosciusko morizet pour bien fonctionner
l'opposition parisienne qui repose sur
ces deux piliers ne serai supporter de
dissonances surtout dans une fédération
aussi riche de fortes et talentueuse
personnalités telles que je les vois
rassemblés dans les premiers rangs le
rassemblement et l'union constitue notre
quête permanente et les réunions de
travail régulières fréquente que
tiennent les maires d'arrondissement les
parlementaires et les cadres militants
aussi bien dans le comité stratégique de
la fédération que dans les réunions de
préparation du conseil aux groupes en
sont l'illustration et la désignation
unanime de pierre-yves bournazel comme
tête de liste régionale à paris en est
une autre preuve
mais c'est d'autant plus facile que nous
partageons tous la même conception d'une
opposition résolue à la politique
néfaste de la municipalité rose rouge
verte dont le dernier avatar et ce
projet fumeux de cette réforme assez
soudaine du statut de paris
cette annonce traduit une certaine
panique pour ne pas dire plus bonjour
chers sénateurs
on va l'installer et aussi bien sûr et
bien c'est à ce titre que nous savions
tous ceux gens chez nous que nous
applaudissions pour sa présence parmi
nous et son arrivée triomphale
c'est une panique sans doute de madame
hidalgo qui visiblement anticipe la
double défaite des régionales et du
grand paris en essayant vous l'avez bien
compris d'accaparer tout le pouvoir à
son profit sans évidemment en laisser la
moindre miette aux arrondissements et
sans permettre comme partout en france
l'élection du maire de paris directement
par les électeurs
dans cet arrondissement to call 15e où
on la connaît bien la liste qu'elle
conduisait je rappelle au passage a subi
une défaite cinglante ramenant la gauche
25 ans en arrière
n'est ce pas mon cher jean avec à peine
un peu plus de 35% des voix contre 48 en
2008 et je ferai tout comme maire de cet
arrondissement avec jean françois lamour
pour que ce précédent ne restent pas
unique
soyez en sûr est que madame hidalgo
répondent donc à quelques questions
simples vit-on mieux à paris depuis son
élection il pète au moins d'impôts
les tarifs municipaux ont ils baissé
trouve-t-on plus facilement un logement
les déplacements sont ils plus facile la
sécurité y est elle mieux assurer le
chômage at-il régressé voilà vous avez
donné la réponse le pilon est accablant
et la liste pour être encore plus longue
ne sous-estimez pas non plus mes chers
amis l'affaiblissement qui serait le 6
en cas de défaite aux régionales
les maires d'arrondissement de notre
formation sortirait aussi renforcé il
pourrait alors bénéficier de politiques
plus favorables d'un conseil régional
davantage orienté alors vers l'emploi
la baisse des impôts et des charges le
développement des transports
la lutte contre la sécurité ou
l'amélioration de la propreté de nos
rues comme s'y sont engagés
valérie et pierre-yves pour terminer je
rappellerai mon cher nicolas que les
parisiens ne doivent pas oublier non
plus que tu as fait pour eux comme
président de la république
nous avons quinté réalisations sur le
plan parisien
en lançant le métro du futur celui du
grand paris en imposant avec françois
fillon à une municipalité plus que
réticents que le plan vidéoprotection
financé à 95 % par l'état en proposant à
l'ouverture de salles de shoot en
décidant la construction des deux plus
grands nouveaux équipements publics
parisiens que sont le tribunal de grande
instance aux batignolles chère brigitte
et le ministère de la défense à balard
en octroyant à la ville de paris des
dotations budgétaires autrement plus
généreuses que celles attribuées par le
gouvernement actuel en affectant les
investissements d'avenir à la rénovation
de pitau et autres en relançant la
construction de logements etc
je ne suis pas tout à fait certain pour
vous dire la vérité mes chers amis que
la coopération actuelle entre l'état et
la ville pourtant de la même obédience
politique et permis d'aussi importantes
réalisations on compte plutôt à ce
moment les coûts les coups bas échangés
entre la maire de paris et le ministre
de l'économie
avec le ministre de l'environnement ou
encore avec le milieu des affaires
étrangères jusqu'à matignon
ou serait-ce alors une nouvelle
stratégie fort politicienne et
inattendue d'une mère de paris qui se
verrait bien un jour peut-être à
l'elysée après hollande hidalgo non
merci alors nous ici on a quelques
autres idées en tête dans cette salle
pour trouver un successeur au président
sortant et bientôt sorti et je crois
pouvoir affirmer que madame hidalgo
n'est pas dans nos pensées
pas plus d'ailleurs que dans celle des
français je conclurai en me réjouissant
dieu renouveau de notre parti un parti
moderne où le débat est désormais
assumée vous pouvez voter sur le choix
des candidats et des projets comme vous
l'avez fait sur l'immigration le code du
travail ou la transparence est de mise à
tous les niveaux pour redonner confiance
aux français qui ne croient plus
beaucoup c'est vraiment la politique
vous tous vous avez tenu bon quand il le
fallait
et aujourd'hui vous mobiliser pour faire
gagner notre parti et notre région vous
tous vous croyez en la force de
l'engagement politique
d'abord parce que vous aimez votre pays
et que vous voulez le meilleur pour lui
vous serez donc j'en suis sûr et nous en
sommes tous persuadés ici au rendez vous
pour que tous ensemble nous donnions ce
nouvel élan pour la france